foreign
good morning
we're just gonna go live now okay
welcome to this babera overview and
scrutiny committee i am councillor mary
mclaren and i am chairing the meeting
today
may i first of all remind you of some
domestic arrangements
please ensure that you maintain a social
distance from all of the persons in the
chamber and in the social areas
please ensure that you wear a mask
unless you are speaking or if you are
unable to do so and that you
use the hand sanitizer and wipes
provided
please maintain social distance at all
times during the meeting and during any
breaks please ensure that microphones
are turned off when not in use
that you do not interrupt other speakers
that if you were attending the meeting
to speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or switched off
additionally we will be using e-voting
for this meeting on the modern
dot
app
i would like to remind everyone present
at this meeting that it will be
broadcast live to the internet and will
be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those images and sound
recordings for webcasting and or
training purposes
[Applause]
the council members of the public and
the press may record
film
photograph or broadcast this meeting
when the public and the press are not
lawfully excluded
can i just remind members and anybody
attending that to ensure that we can all
hear well
that
all our electric
our laptops and things are not in front
of the
microphone i think we all have a habit
of doing that
in attendance today
we have
our offices the assistant director of
assets and investments
assistant director for corporate
resources and the section 151 officer
and we have
cabinet members so we have councillor
dave busby cabinet member for assets and
investments and councillor simon barrett
member cabinet member for finance
can i move to the agenda please
apologize for absence
good morning chair we have received
apologies from councillor grandin and
councillor hinton
have we any declarations of bikinary and
non-pecuniary interests by members
nontradica okay
um
we are here uh on item three to the
calling protocol for the weber cabinet
decision of the 7th of february
2022. i refer to the calling protocol
attached in the agenda and ask members
to approve the call-in protocol before
we proceed
could i have a proposal please
thank you councillor gold and the
seconder please
thank you councillor osborne
the governance officer will now conduct
the electronic vote
thank you
thank you chair the vote is now in
progress on your app
chair that's unanimous
can i just query that number
i have three votes four okay
thank you
i now come to item four of the agenda
and uh this is the calling of the baby
cabinet decision for bca stroke 21
stroke 38
accommodation
and agile strategy
endeavour house
i will now introduce the calling
i believe the paper that was presented
to cabinet on monday
bca stroke 21 stroke 38 did not contain
sufficient information on the capital
costs of the works proposed for cabinet
to make an informed decision
6.7 of the report states
the total cost per council would be 250
000 pounds
and the total net saving per council
would be
338 000 pounds
the later calculation has been explained
the former is referred to in the
following point
that is 6.8 in the report
the capital costs are estimated and will
be refined during the technical design
stage of the project
this is the only reference made in the
paper with no breakdown on how the 250
000 pounds will be spent
this is compounded by the fact that this
is just a share of the overall costs
as it is split across both councils
at the cabinet on the 7th of february
which i attended and watched on youtube
i noted that no cabinet member asked
questions on costs
or debated these elements of this issue
my contention is that the cabinet
approved the paper on a reduction to the
floor plate
but neglected to consider the
expenditure
there should be an opportunity to
examine debate and vote on the capital
costs once these details are
available this is a key decision as
proposed expenditure is over one hundred
and fifty thousand pounds
to fully comply with our constitution
councillors must fully consider
all the circumstances
see extract below from the notice
displayed on the forthcoming decision
list
this has not happened
a key decision as per part one
12.9.1 in the constitution is an
executive decision which is likely to
one
result in the council spending
or saving a significant amount compared
with the budget for the service or
function the decision relates to
two
have a significant effect on communities
living or working in an area made up of
two or more wards
when assessing whether or not a decision
is key
is a key decision sorry counsellors must
consider all the circumstances of the
case
however a decision which results in a
significant amount spent or saved will
generally be considered to be a con
a key decision if one
the amount spent is
150 000 pounds or more of revenue or
capital expenditure
expenditure on this scale
must not be delegated
calling was signed by the following
councillors
councillor melanie barrett
councillor trevor cresswell
councillor mick fraser
councillor jane gould
councillor margaret mabry councillor
mark newman
i will now invite
the lead signatory
councillor melanie barrett to present
the reason for the calling
and why the committee should scrutinize
the decision
councillor barrett you have a maximum of
10 minutes
you may call on other councils from
those listed on the council calling
notice which i just read out
but i don't see anybody present so you
have a whole 10 minutes to yourself
thank you
thank you chair um good morning
councillors and officers um
i've called this to the ovu and scrutiny
committee because i believe that the as
mary has outlined in my
um my submission to the committee
this is a such a significant
amount of money that is proposed to be
spent
[Music]
when when i first wrote it i thought i
might have misread it i thought it might
have been 50 000 but it was indeed half
a million pounds to be spent on half the
work half the workspace that that we
previously occupied
so the benefits um
appear to be a net saving of 88 000
however
does this saving come at a cost to
service delivery and our
um
that that is also a concern uh although
the majority of my uh reason for
referring it is due to the the um lack
of scrutiny on the how that money will
be allocated
um
the decision
cannot be sent to be made on on such a
ballpark figure
um
his previous history of of calculations
have shown this
there is no detail
and indeed
having looked at papers for today's
budget i note that in in that paper
it under the general fund budget it
talks about the key elements of
the the council's responsibility and one
of those is cost management
so
i understand there may be also be a
margin of error within these
calculations we we can't assess that
until we are given uh more more detail
i don't believe that we saw
in the original papers the floor plan
that's now
included in this and i see the there's a
branding graphics wall a green graphics
wall
and a full height green wall
perhaps if that had been
ex included with i presume there would
be costs available
for us to understand
how that
cost could amount to half a million
pounds
that would have have helped the the
cabinet to to
uh
make make better use of their
uh their questions to understand the
the how that uh figure is arrived at
um
it is
i understand also that some of the cost
is sound proofing meeting rooms
um
but that's not clear from the the paper
whether the landlord has been approached
uh to see if they would shoulder some of
those costs
um that that should be um our first
option to to make sure that the landlord
was
um going to um going to share those
costs
um
it's in it's unbalanced as well um there
were
potential costs were were looked at as a
ballpark figure
but there hasn't been an assessment of
the impacts um
on productivity and output
um it seems that the primary move is to
serve the needs of officers
um
and residents
will only benefit um
indirectly if at all
um
and so there is a saving but just
because there is a saving that does not
mean this is free money
um
that can be
just just uh unaccounted for
there is always a cost there is a um
there is a other options that we could
spend that money on
so
just to look at this in some contexts as
well
um this this
expenditure 250 000
uh some councillors have spent the last
16 months
arguing the case for imposing parking
charges
um where it would estimate it was
estimated that we would raise 212
000
but the same degree of scrutiny has not
even been shown to to to that
to to this issue
um it's it's it's sort of been um been
been just uh just taken for on face
value
in my view an even greater degree of
scrutiny than normal must be applied
here as the money will directly benefit
the staff and the staff are making the
decision
with only a minimal
input from councillors
it only indirectly benefits our
residents if at all
indeed this move could be could actually
be detrimental to residents
whether they might see a reduction in
service precision lengthening service
times or reduced access to to officers
i urge you to make recommendations to
cabinet to demand greater breakdown of
cost
analysis of the impact of the
the the changes that your
have been approved
thank you
thank you councillor barrett
before we ask questions of councillor
barrett i'm going to call on
uh invite the cabinet member for us
assets and investments council david
busby to present the reason why the
decision was taken by the cabinet and
you have ten minutes councillor busby
thank you chair
morning everybody
the cabinet supported the
recommendations within the accommodation
and agile strategy for endeavour house
report on the 7th of february
these recommendations were to reduce and
reconfigure the floor play for space
within endeavour house and to delegate
authority to the assistant director for
assets and investments to deliver these
changes
the reasons for these decisions were set
out in the report mainly to create fit
for purpose accommodation at endeavour
house to deliver financial savings over
the full term of the lease
and to enable timely efficient
and effective delivery of the project
council about has contested that the
report presented to cabinet did not
contain sufficient information on the
capital cost of the works proposal
cabinet to make an informed decision
the section six of the report sets out
the financial implications of this
decision resulting in a saving of three
hundred and thirty six thousand for
waiver
after estimated costs of 250 000 pounds
the estimated capital costs are based on
the concept drawings provided by
concertos and are sufficient for
budgeting purposes
detailed costs will not be available
until the full technical design has been
completed and the works tendered
but even with
costs rising we anticipate coming in
under budget
waiting for the detail cost is not an
option as the notice to trigger the
break clause must be served before the
end of march 2022
cabinet has to take the decision before
then otherwise the councils will lose
the legal ability to end the lease for
one of the floor plates
councillor barrett has also contested
that the cabinet approved the paper on a
reduction to the floor plate but
neglected to consider the expenditure
but whilst there may not have been any
questions directly relating to the
capital cost of this project during the
cabinet meeting this does not mean that
the cabinet failed to give it due
consideration it means that we were
content with the information provided
cabinet members or other members such as
council of barrow who attended the
meeting had adequate opportunity to
raise any such concerns or questions in
this regard
finally council barrett states her
concerns that a key decision about
expenditure should not be delegated
this is a key decision made by the
cabinet and was advertised as such ahead
of the cabinet making the decision in
accordance with our constitution
the decision to adopt the
recommendations was made by cabinet and
implementation delegated to officers
this is normal practice and in line with
our constitution
i'm happy to
answer questions
and enter into the debate later cheers
thank you
thank you councillor buzzfeed
i now ask members of the committee
to ask questions of the lead signatory
councillor melanie barrett or councillor
dave busby
who would like to uh
councillor gold
thank you for that councillor busby
can i just ask um you say that cabinet
were aware of the content of how the
expenditure was was arrived at how that
250 figure
um had actually been popped into the
into the chart there
and they didn't need to ask questions
because they were aware of it
and that's okay
but any members of the public listening
to that cabinet meeting wouldn't have
had that information
so it it would be perceived by members
of the public or indeed other
councillors listening to that cabinet
meeting
that it was just almost nodded through
so i think my question would be
if members of the cabinet were aware
of that break of how that 250 000 is
broken down
why wasn't it why wasn't that question
asked so that there could have been a
record and the public could have been
privy to the information as well
the actual
content of the 250 000 pounds i don't
think was
it wasn't broken down into in very
minute details it that way the the the
project this as a whole was considered
so it was a
bearing in mind there were there were a
number of
reasons for doing this it wasn't just
finance
okay the prime concern is to get the
offices into a fit state for people to
return to and for us to deliver our
services and it was determined that the
best way to do that would be to release
half of the space
and to reconfigure the remaining space
this would generate a saving it would
create offices that were fit for purpose
for the for foregoing future
the cost
of 500 000 pounds for the total or 250
000 per council may seem significant but
savings
are much greater than that
you know if you
if you went to any finance person and
said
here's a project it'll pay back within a
couple of years and continue going on to
give you
savings they'd bite your hand off
can i come back with i i agree with all
of that that's not my point i don't know
whether you can easily find the bit in
your statement that you read can you
and reread it to us
can you easily find the bit in your
statement that you read to us and
re-read it
um
the bit where you said cabinet were
aware of it
well i mentioned that detail costs
weren't going to be available until
we've yeah it wasn't that bad okay
you're thinking where there may not have
any questions relating directly rating
to the capital costs of this project
during the cabinet meeting this does not
mean that the cabinet failed to give it
to due consideration
it means that we were content with the
information provided yes yeah and the
next bit
and
cabinet members and or other members of
the council including camp uh councillor
barrett who attended
had adequate opportunity to raise any
such concerns or questions in this
regard the the bit that said that you
were content with the information
provided
i'm assuming that you were provided with
more information than than we've got on
the expenditure otherwise are you saying
that you were content with the 250 000
spend without any
any detail of the breakdown
i mean i think
the the information they had was the
budget figure which has been of 250 000
the total spend
we haven't we haven't broken that down i
mean we've um they recently got the
uh breakdown of the cost summary
from our consultants
um
and again this is not the final figure
because we aren't at the detailed stage
yet oh yes
it's i mean we're all i don't with that
cost for any sort of building worker on
the up um and nobody can put a final
figure on it because you know um costs
are in a state of flux um with both
brexit and covet happening together it's
a perfect storm in terms of trying to
assess expenditure isn't it but
nevertheless the 250
um can't have been an arbitrary figure
that was plucked out of the air it must
have come from somewhere and i i think
that's what we would like a little bit
more that's what i would like a little
bit more detail on and how that figure
was actually arrived at don't dispute
the fact that the savings are there
absolutely but how was that 250 pound
figure arrived at
well the
figures were provided by our consultants
they produced an estimate
of the total costs
and have since come up with a number of
options
and costed those out
okay
can i um yeah
council goes sorry to interrupt
we do have on the agenda actually
an opportunity for us to question the
assistant director for
investments
but in asset and investments but in fact
this might be a good opportunity just to
assist councillor busby to um is that if
that's all right with you uh emily
thank you very much
that's fine thank you and so the budget
figures were provided um with our
consultants uh concertos who had uh
developed the concept plan which was
included in the in the report so i think
it was appendix one but also included as
a smaller version of the plan within the
body of the report so the estimate was
um based on that that drawing and
provided to us by concertus
until we have the full technical uh
design worked through and
until we've gone out to tender
effectively for those works we're not
able to provide any further detail but
conservatives are obviously very
experienced in delivering these kinds of
refurbishment projects and so they
thought that was an appropriate budget
and as councillor busby
stated we probably have been on the
cautious side because of
the rising costs and that we're seeing
in the market at the current time and we
would hope to be able to deliver the
project under budget
moving forward but we are in quite a
challenging time in terms of contractual
pricing and availability
thank you council do you have any
questions for councillor barrett
just just one i think really yes um
council about
your comment that um
the project would benefit officers
um but
there will be no quantifiable benefit to
our residents i think i would i just
have a um a question there around surely
if
our offices are benefited because the
offices our officers working
are improved
and the working conditions are improved
and
i'm sure that all of our baby staff
i know that well-being is is sort of key
um as
a consideration
surely if our officers are happy in
their offices our residents will be
benefited
maybe not
a quantifiable pound shillings and pence
benefit but happy officers equate to
more content residents because it
trickles it trickles down that way
doesn't it so i would just ask whether
you would agree with me really
um
i think i said um indirectly that
officers will benefit directly and
residents will benefit indirectly
so
but
whether the end user whether the
the uh the person having their bins
emptied or
phoning up the the council for
assistance of some sort will actually be
able to
benefit from
the
the offices being refurbished is a very
very remote possibility i feel
um
it's really it's really difficult
to quantify totally totally impossible
to quantify really
um yes we obviously we want off um
employees staff to
to have um a modern uh work environment
where um they can
meet and uh do their best work
um
but i think they've got that already to
be honest
i think this is a modern a modern uh
dedicated workspace it's not like some
some it's not like corks lane which was
um quite an old building quite uh had
its quirks this is a very dedicated
building it's it's it's got meeting
space dedicated it's got breakout areas
it's got all those things that people
can do their best work here so i don't i
don't feel that um perhaps perhaps even
the officers don't benefit that much
from this perhaps it is the the benefits
are
quite difficult to to discern really
does that answer your question
um
i think so
um
i think that there's a few things there
around workspace
and with people working remotely now
however modern and newer building is
um as the work pattern changes
the fixtures and fittings of the
workplace
need to change accordingly i think
[Music]
yeah yeah
i have no more questions
to make it easy could we perhaps address
questions to counselor barrett first and
then go on to councillor
busby um
i'm afraid i
i uh councillor gould's questions have
been
well explained and i believe um
councillor busby's answers have been uh
really well put and
i
you know uh the budget figures on by the
consultants who took on board this
project
is uh is one where you need to identify
you i cannot
i cannot see uh as councillor gould has
explained
i cannot see
the
the figures here um
against the breakdown of the various
works
you know
works i've worked in in in major
buildings with lloyds for years and
uh
it does cost money i know that probably
won't be that for it but building works
itself will be quite horrendous i should
imagine and the changes of uh um
h and v heating and ventilation and also
um electrics will also be very large but
i'd like to see you do you have a
question i haven't i haven't i'm afraid
because in fact
well questioned by council okay because
we've got we've got an opportunity to
discuss our
um
councillor barrett i don't have a
question for you but i have questions
for councillor busby
um actually the first
my first question was around the one
that councillor gould asked which was
given that the cabinet has a duty to
explore all circumstances around a
decision um
i just wondered why
no questions had been raised by cabinet
members in relation to the decision but
i think
councillor gold asked that question
but it just um
unless you'd like to add to that
counselor busby
so i didn't quite get the question
well
because
there was the next we were looking at
the expenditure of 250 000 pounds which
is
quite
significant it's over the amount
that is to do with a key decision
um
i was just wondering why cabinet members
had really not explored that
during the cabinet meeting because it's
important to the public
to hear
why was no questions raised around the
finances of the
well i i i assume that they
trusted the estimates
given by the consultants i mean when you
think um 500 000 pounds sounds a lot and
somebody said how can you spend 500 000
pounds of furniture well we not
the furniture comes to i don't know
probably
300 000 sorry 150 000 of that
it's nowhere near the ultimate cost
there when you do these works there's a
considerable amount of as
council osborne said there's a
considerable amount of construction work
involved there's
detail um
work in terms of design there's
demolition works
there's a whole host of things
these are the costs that we're still
waiting to get the detail on but the
cabinet members would understand that in
a project of this size it isn't just a
case of buying another 110
new chairs
that doesn't explain why nobody asked
any questions
well i can't answer that i don't know
the mo inside the minds of all of our
cabinet members especially certain
cabinet members
yes chair you can ask other cabinet
members
to comment yes thank you councillor
barrett i just uh had to check the press
the process really
yeah i mean i i was not in favor of this
i
feel that the uh subject is um
on two issues
and they need to be treated separately
so on the issue of the lease being
revoked or or the break clause uh i
don't have a problem with that and
that's a sensible option
that's one area so i think the cabinet
we're voting
primarily on that
because that was part
i did not vote i was one of three
cabinet members that did not vote for
this motion so um in my mind
i was not happy
with that that uh the the spend element
but i couldn't separate that out
so if you look at the the vote it was a
vote in total not his two separate
issues
had it been in two separate issues i
would have voted to
withdraw
and hand in the uh break clause because
i think that's sensible we clearly don't
need as much space
what i wasn't happy with and i and
reflected in my overall vote
was that the uh figures of half a
million pounds did not represent
i don't think um and as a cabinet member
for finance i find it difficult to
justify
but obviously i could not vote and we
had a time limit
on on this which is crucial so from your
committee's point of view i think the
time limit needs to be
uh recognized and the break clause needs
to be put forward
but i would say the spending issue on
the 500 000 for the
refurbishment of
what is only a four-year-old office
needs to be questions and that is where
as another cabinet member that's where i
came from
if that's helpful to you thank you
council about well we will make our own
decisions based on our own discussion
um councillor busby i've got some more
questions for you if that's okay respond
to
that first or not
okay
well
i think the office is older than four
years um
2017. well the building's been a lot and
i'd question as to
look there are two elements to this
and it's not just about cost saving the
cost saving well yes we could do that as
councillor bharata said we could just do
the cost saving
that means that we then retain the
office as is
and there's a question as to whether
that's suitable councillor barrett
melanie barrett thinks it is suitable
personally i don't think it is working
patterns have changed i find the offices
totally uninspiring they're
characterless
they don't promote the right kind of uh
mental attitude that we want from our
staff in my opinion they'll they go back
to the 60s and 70s where we used to have
typing pools they're just the wrong kind
of office environment for going forward
and yes it makes a huge difference if
the staff feel as though they've got the
right facilities to work in and
the right ambience there it makes a
difference to their performance
and therefore to me it is worth
doing
for that and if you're going to do that
if you're going to make a change
it's going to cost some
funds yes it is
but the savings are there as well
you can't underestimate the benefit to
the the
working of the staff from a change like
this and i think it will be significant
and i'll
relate a little story later
i think we've um i think we've got to go
back to the content of the calling
actually and keep our minds on that
uh we're drifting a bit into other areas
the calling is about 250
000 pounds that has not been explained
and this the cabinet exploring
circumstances
around the decision they made to approve
that so i want to actually stick with
that
in reading the papers and i've read all
the papers
i did not find any inaccuracies
but i did feel
that as a non-cabinet member there were
some figures like proposed savings that
were
quoting the overall cost to both
councils rather than beiber district
council now in my
in my thinking uh the paper was being
presented by babera district council
and so i probably was looking for
figures that
were specific to babera district council
but i thought that was confusing in the
paper
but
as as a layperson i
would like to i felt we should go back
to basics and i didn't see this in the
report
which was the starting point and so
councillor busby i'd like to know
whether you can tell me
what the annual cost presently
of the lease
is
for gold plate and lime plate
i'll have to refer to my uh steamed
experts
on the left okay i can't give you
thank you so um the table in section six
and does show the total total costs and
because that's actually how the savings
are built up
and
so it's just about inverting those but
in terms of the
the rent we currently have a rent of 164
000 pounds per annum uh business rates
payable of around 80 000 pounds um and
service charges as well of around about
170 000 pounds per annum for both lime
and gold floor plates
so and i think catherine might have
added that up for me it's about 405
464 000. yep that's right
for somebody like me
uh would have been helpful to have
started with that and then taking the
figures from that
what that does give us if there is a
break in the and perhaps somebody can
confirm this if there's a break in the
in the lease
um
we get six months benefit because the
the breaking the lease
the operating break will be from
september to march
so i made that
58k
which is comes up in the table on 6.4
you can see that
okay thank you um however
the
capital costs that have been uh proposed
are not the only cost
and i wondered
if you have um
a ballpark figure
um
for the dilapidations
which will be required to be paid for to
the county council in the event in the
break in the in the lease the operating
braking release
can can i answer that thank you so
within the report um there is a sentence
that says that there is um budget for uh
within the corporate buildings revenue
budget for dilapidations now
dilapidations are a matter for
negotiation between the landlord and
tenant so i don't think it's appropriate
in public session to be sharing
and that that figure because that could
uh compromise our ability to negotiate a
good position with our with our landlord
and so that that's why that figure is
excluded from um from the report
but presumably emily if the cabinet
because this is a discussion about a
cabinet decision
we're not really debating
the
outcome of the paper
if
the cabinet
had actually
wanted to question
the dilapidations
could that have been
discussed in private session
and
yes anything can always be discussed in
private session if it's
taken outside of um a
public session
and but again i think in terms of the
dilapidations until we have those
uh completed those negotiations with the
landlord we won't know what that amount
is there are different ways of
approaching dilapidations
you can either undertake the works
yourselves before the expiry of the
lease as a tenant or the landlord can
seek to claim damages at the end of the
lease for the works that have not been
undertaken those damages are limited by
the diminution in value
and so it's quite difficult to
provide anything other than an estimate
in terms of what the the dilapidation
expenditure is likely to be until you
get beyond the um expiry of the lease
councillor busby but that never actually
was raised was it within cabinet even if
even if you've got the the
figure in private
were dilapidations ever discussed within
cabinet and the cost for dilapidations
no
but the
he seemed to miss the point that the
cabinet members and members of council
that were at the meeting had the
opportunity to ask that question if they
felt there was
some concern over it
we didn't hide it
it was
the you know the question was there for
the asking if they needed to know the
information
the second cost is the adaptations which
of course is being calculated as 250 000
for baby district council
and i think we've had
this was one of my questions but i think
we've had an explanation from emily
about what those costs include
but what my question is around that
that's not included
we have
used concertus the um
external consultants
do we have any costs so far
on
you know what what they've undertaken
because they've undertaken quite a bit
of work i think already do you have
those figures
thank you councillor mclaren so we have
a budget for um fees for conserters for
around fifteen thousand pounds of which
around about six thousand pounds have
been um incurred to date
and emily does that come out of this
that that's already come out of this
year's budget presumably uh the six
thousand pounds will be um
yes we'll have come out of a property um
budget so one of the corporate uh budget
codes and but if the project goes
forward then those fees will be
capitalized because it's a capital
project so it will be within the um
numbers included in the report
thank you
i asked you about the staff survey
because yeah i wasn't present at the
cabinet meeting so i remember you giving
some figures around that could you just
explain that for us sort of how many
people responded and what was the
percentage of people that um
you know
favored hybrid working
the change in the uh working
arrangements
yeah i mean the staff service hasn't
just been completed emily's got the
latest figures on that so sorry
the staff survey's just been completed
and emily has the latest figures on that
okay thank you emily
thank you so um i think the uh staff
survey that councillor busby's referring
to is one that we've undertaken recently
and doesn't relate directly to this um
project so in terms of the um survey for
um
the staff survey in relation to this we
had
221 and respondents that's around about
55 of endeavour house and base staff who
responded and the
overrate the the main reasons wanting to
come back into the office or for
returning to the office were
social interaction
and collaboration which was around about
57
overall they were the key drivers for
returning to to the office and other
reasons were meeting space as well so um
collaboration was a really strong theme
in terms of reasons for coming back into
the office
so
50 of the 221
were
looking uh no so we had 221 respondents
which is around about 55 percent of
endeavor house-based
staff
and
57
of those respondents said the main
reasons for wanting to come back into
endeavour house were for social
interaction and collaboration reasons
and with a further 15
um saying meeting space and desk space
was around about seven percent
thank you
i was just um interested because we have
a workforce of 579 people
um whole time equivalence 525
so that was 50 really and and councillor
busby can i come back to you do you
think
that is reflective enough of the of the
um
the workforce
which i think is pretty pretty high
percentage
return on that then all office based
either
of the 500 and whatever it was 75 that
you mentioned they're not all office
based so
um
yeah i think that's a pretty good return
i think one thing that's been failed to
be mentioned is that we did have uh a
working group counsellor working group
which has been going on for i don't know
six months eight months nine months uh
we've met at least three times
uh joint working group on this project
it's not just something which i or
emily has come up with and presented to
cabinet it's been
discussed
at the working group and hopefully the
working group has then taken that
information back to their political
groups
for this for information and for
debate
this isn't this isn't a surprise when it
came to cabinet
at least it shouldn't have been
thank you um just linked to that the uh
there was a
an assessment under dsc so that making
sure that
people
sorry
thank you everyone i think councillor
buzzfeed covered it already i was just
going to make the observation that
obviously yes you're right in terms of
the total number of staff that we have
but they aren't all based at endeavour
house clearly a large number of those
work uh out of the depots and are out in
the districts every day rather than
being office based
uh the the assessments of people working
from home
do you has anybody considered the cost
of that
because there's an
assessment has been can be undertaken
under health and safety at work can't
they to make sure that
working from home is safe
thank you councillor mclaren so we have
been undertaking dse assessments
throughout the pandemic to ensure that
our staff are working safely and there
isn't an additional cost to those
assessments per se and they're managed
by our health and safety team um in
so internally to our own corporate
resource and if there are
issues that are
that arise through those assessments and
then as a council we have been offering
um some support to ensure that those
members of staff can work safely and so
whether that's been providing additional
equipment like chairs or screens or
providing a contribution towards um
chairs if if needed and so that has
already been undertaken over the last
two years whilst we've been working in
this in this way during the pandemic
thank you
and my final question councillor busby
i'm sure you're pleased
um
i asked this question at cabinet so i'm
asking the same question again
what if
it
doesn't work out as we planned
and the reason i asked the question
is that the suffolk county council
obviously is our landlord
uh the loss of 232
000 pounds a year in rent
is quite a substantial sum for them
you would expect somebody who are good
managers of public money as a county
council
would very quickly fill the spaces left
with partners of the county council so
what do we do in the event of
this
proposed plan not working out properly
like any proposed plan you would
reconsider
and
act accordingly if you're saying
that there's not enough workspaces
we may have to reconfigure the office
times are changing
if we do nothing it may not be the right
thing to do
all i can think of is
staff have got the opportunity to come
back into the office now
how many are how many are coming back
are they enticed into the office
do they feel as though they want to come
in
obviously not because there's never
anybody here or very few people here
we've got issues
collaboration social interaction
meetings these are the reasons why
people want to come back to the office
and that office doesn't meet those
requirements in my view
so you would need to consider if if it
doesn't work in terms of numbers well we
can alter the uh the configuration of
the office
thank you
well that's the end of my questions uh
the committee
councillor gould have any more questions
that you've
considered during the
time counselor or spawn
oh council barrett sorry
yeah
okay sorry
um i've got two questions actually well
i um
actually emily's answered one of them
but i i have got a question for the
section 151 officer catherine
uh
where in
we're going to be looking at the
budget tonight uh in council
um
where is this proposed expenditure um
located in the budget papers
so that we can have a look at them
thank you chair
yes the capital table within the budget
papers tonight is contained within
appendix a of the general fund report
so it's page 39 of the the council
report pack
um and within that table there is a
heading entitled investment and
commercial delivery
and the first item that is within that
section is called planned maintenance
stroke enhancements
of corporate buildings
and there is a figure proposed in there
of 330 000 pounds for 2223
thousand pounds of that is a an annual
contingency that we put in for just sort
of emergency works to buildings uh but
the other three hundred thousand is what
we have put put into the proposed budget
to cover the enhancement worker endeavor
house
and
i think
some explanation about
which
which pot of money
i think is something perhaps
those of us are not involved with
finance very often which
pot of money would that come out of
and
because i know what was said in the
report it said it would come from
borrowings
um so
where would it come from and would there
be be any interest
to be paid on those borrowings thank you
yes the funding source as you've rightly
said is from borrowing that that's one
of the the options that we have in terms
of funding capital expenditure and for
this particular project there isn't
another option so it is it is borrowing
um the report that came into cabinet had
the minimum revenue provision which is
one of the revenue costs of borrowing in
the report
the interest element wasn't specifically
mentioned
but i did look very quickly at that and
base rate at the moment is half a
percent which is about where we do
borrow
so over the five year period that we
would be repaying the borrowing which is
the remaining term of the lease that
cost would come to about seven and a
half thousand pounds so over that five
year period so in comparison to the cost
of the actual building works then the
interest is is very minimal
thank you very much uh catherine
any further questions
from the committee before we go to the
next
stage of the agenda
so
i would like to now invite the cabinet
member for assets investments
councillor dave
busby to provide a summary of his case
and you have five minutes councillor
busby
thank you chair
um which it seems to me that there's two
elements to this there's the first
element is the is the finance
did we give sufficient information for
uh cabinet to make the decision i think
given the fact that this project has
been ongoing for nine months or so
there's been work in groups and there's
been feedback
to the cabinet and to all council
members
we fed back the information that we had
which was the best estimate of the costs
from the concern from consultants who
know the building
having worked you know they've been
occupied this in this building so they
know the building it's not new to them
so i expect that their estimates should
be very professional
and a total amount
of 250 000 per council which is
not unreasonable for the amount of work
that was doing that was needed to me the
most the more important element of this
is
the need to do it
we can reduce the
the floor space we know that we've said
that
but is there a need to
reconfigure
and refurbish the space that's left
and in my view it's a significant
need
don't i think you shouldn't understand
the importance of the ambience of the
working place just a quick uh story as i
said i was going to mention
47 years ago when i was working at
ford's i looked looking for a new job
and i had two interviews one with stc in
hendon
and one with willis in ipswich
i went to hendon
took me two hours to get through the
north circular i was greeted i was put
through two hours of psychometric
testing
then interviews i wasn't interviewed
introduced to the staff there was paint
hanging off the walls the radiators were
this thick the pla it was an awful place
i went back to willis you walk in the
door and wow
why wouldn't you want to work there
it's an unbelievable building inside
and it was reflected in the staff
i was late i was two hours late for my
interview because of this blooming
interview in stc but
they were great and no problem they took
me around to interview see the staff the
staff are happy they work better
and that's the kind of environment that
gets the best out of the staff and
that's what we need to do here
it's an opportunity and we need to do it
if you accept that there's going to be a
cost involved
and 250 000 per council is not an
unreasonable
cost to deliver
the new working patterns that we're
looking
for
we've experienced it with our um
a lot of our clients
uh on
um
where we act as the landlord they
they're requiring us to update the
offices it's time for it to be done
the office space isn't
future proof in my opinion
thank you councillor busby
sorry
just the point of mentioning my story
was not to try and
tell you about the differences in the
working space the important point is
that 47 years later i still tell that
story about the differences in the
working environment that's how important
it is
thank you councillor busby we've noted
your
your presentation and your experiences
i'd like to invite the lead signatory
counsellor melanie barrett to provide a
summary on her case and you have got
five minutes
thank you um
well listening to to some of the issues
that have been raised and debated uh
just quickly um run through a couple of
points i want to make um
yes we understand building costs are
expensive um
that doesn't mean that um
that we can't analyze uh and and make
informed decisions about that with with
more information
on what that cost is precisely because
it is a lot of money
and there's no going back afterwards as
well it's uh it's a very final decision
that alters our working environment
permanently
and could stop more people coming back
into the office in future should they uh
they find that home working is not so
suitable again so talk i've talked a
cabinet about
this is not an
a suitable option for
everyone there are different
circumstances that people have and
working from the office environment for
many people
is the the best
environment the best place that they can
[Music]
work from
that's so that's not the issue here i
don't believe and and it's distracting
to look at that really
if the expense had been known
in in more detail
um
the specs should have been clearer um i
do not believe that that
plan was available to the cabinet when
they made the decision
if it had been then i'm sure someone
would have said what's what's this green
wall what's a branding graphics wall
what are these
and that has not been raised at all
um these things might come in at a
significant cost i have no idea
um but it would have allowed a greater
scrutiny greater understanding of what
what was being proposed for our new
working space
um
they i mean
sure and i accept that um a
more detailed technical spec
would have needed to to examine all
those costs in general but um someone
could have advised what sort of ballpark
figure you were talking about for a
green
green wall the branding graphics that
should be available in in a sort of an
estimate form
um councillor busby also suggests this
is a sort of binary choice
we the value our staff and so we must
spend this money or we kind of we don't
care about them let them you know
let them let them work in a sort of
squalored office
this is not a squalid office this is a a
modern office
i haven't heard anyone complain about it
before
about coming into this workspace i've
worked in this building myself so i do
know
that it is
a quite a nice space to work in
is good for collaboration actually
that seems to be one of the mantras that
we're we're talking about here
good for collaborative working this
office can provide that and what i also
found strange about this plan having
seen it in more detail now is that what
you're proposing is to
i think reduce the small office the
glass offices the three
that are set up for about eight people
to to meet in
reduce those and enlarge the two others
so you actually end up with only two
uh meeting rooms in on that floor plate
and i find that a bit strange
when you've got an open plan office
where sometimes you need to escape from
the hubbub going around you and go and
go and have a team meeting that's
separate
um
so i don't accept that
by not not um
uh changing the office space that it's
we're stuck in very sort of last century
or something
this is a suitable office space um
and
and decisions like this must be
accompanied by very detailed
specification on what the proposal is
what the spec is what's so that you can
you can establish what the gain is
if you don't know what the spec is how
can you how can you examine what what
the gain to the
the uh workforce is
i think that's
probably uh you know i'll leave it there
thank you
thank you councillor barrett
well we've come to the end of the
presentations
i now ask that the lead signatory and
the cabinet members leave the meeting
thank you
yes council busby
yes as well
i think it'd be worse just having a
five-minute break
emily i think i'm
you want me to announce it
yes
um
committee i think it would be useful
and officers present i think it would be
useful for us just to have a five-minute
break
uh to give ourselves just
a little gap between all the information
that we've heard
and so we can have a little reflection
on that
so um
do i need to give a time
we come back at 10 45.
thank you
and again good morning sorry about the
break but we're back again and the
overview and scrutiny committee are
going to win
into a period of debate about the
information that we've received
from cabinet members and from offices
so
who would like to
open the debate
councillor osborne
right
just
yes emily that would be really helpful
thank you
thank you chair um part of the protocol
today is for the monitor officer to
comment on whether or not the decision
was in accordance with the budget and
policy framework so um chair if i may i
will make that observation now and i've
also got a couple of comments on the
information that's been presented to the
committee this morning that i'd like to
make if that's okay
so it is my view that the cabinet's
decision was in accordance with agreed
policy and as the section 151 officer
has informed and confirmed today within
the budget
in respect of the information presented
to the committee today
there are a few observations i would
like to make firstly councillor barrett
councillor melanie barrett suggested
that the plan wasn't included in the
cabinet papers
however this was included at appendix a
to the original cabinet report so that
information that layout plan of the the
floor plate was included in the
cabinet's
original reports
secondly chair whilst the debate has
drawn out some very interesting points
around
office design and the impact that it may
have on the effectiveness and
productivity of offices
the call-in specifically related to
financial information and therefore any
recommendations made by the committee
this morning must focus on that aspects
they must be related to the financial
arguments
and finally i would like to confirm that
as in any debate the cabinet does not
necessarily have to discuss an element
of the report to demonstrate that they
have taken that information into account
i.e just because the cabinet did not ask
questions on the financial information
it does not necessarily mean that they
had not taken it into account or
understood the information provided
as such chair i believe there are two
options available to the committee this
morning
firstly to uphold the cabinet's decision
with no further action or to refer the
decision back to cabinet with
recommendations
and the committee must be very specific
about the information that you think the
cabinet needs to reconsider thank you
chair thank you
thank you emily
debate
any counsellor or spawn do you oh
counselor goal do you want to
yes um thank you emily for that
um
one of the things that was
concerning me
was the fact that
perhaps it appeared that
cabinet
hadn't
debated the financial implications of it
but i think
thank you emily you've you've sorted
that one out in my mind for me um that
of course it doesn't necessarily have to
be articulated
um to show that it's been understood
and interesting that factually one or
two of these statements made to us were
incorrect
and thank you for highlighting that
because we don't know
so thank you for pointing that out and
if there were any other factual
inaccuracies i guess it would have come
out as well wouldn't it
um
i think
at the moment that's where my thinking
is
councillor osborne
thank you
madam chairman
if um
if i remember
rightly
officers were tasked to undertake this
piece of work
and this is what they have done
well
we are being provided with an
opportunity to make year-on-year savings
for the taxpayer
in my view endeavor house provides us
with good venue
easy access to good idea other agency
even before covert it was beginning
becoming obvious that we did not require
a current level of floor space
and now we
even require less and flexibility
working for our offices
yes i agree we do need offices to work
from endeavor house most of the week but
as a council we need to provide
flexible working if we are going to be
in a good position to recruit staff
and
thanks to uh emily for her
um
legal uh situation with with what
happened at cabinet and um
that has put me in a good place to
to agree with with
with what uh councillor busby has said
obviously i'm
a little bit disturbed that we the
consultation couldn't have the
amount of um
funding made of where it was going to be
but
as i have obviously worked in facilities
on large buildings in london
um
it is obvious that the landlord or the
lease
or the landlord themselves
has to put back what has to be done with
the areas that we do no longer require
they only have responsibilities for
corridors and staircases
and lighting it's such so
there will be an x
a large amount of money is coming from
into that from from from baber
but other than that i think councillor
busby is right
there's no such thing as
for staff to to to walk into any
building which
doesn't actually provide that ambience
that
they they can be together with and uh
i'm
you know i'm a little bit
uh confused by um
council melanie barrett's uh situation
where
she tends tended to i thought um
contradict what she'd said previously so
whether she was a full understanding
with it i mean i wasn't i'm not
completely update with this but
that's all i can say at present thank
you
thank you councillors
um well personally um
once the calling was called in
then as an overview and scrutiny
we were legally bound to actually
respond to that
and i think we all i think the questions
were asked were very
um
pertinent to
what we'd read in in the report i think
i thought the report um personally
looking through
and i'm talking the report that went to
cabinet
um it could have clarified i think there
were areas where it wasn't quite clear
and so but we are faced we were faced
with the calling
and that was about was there an
explanation and in fact on both because
i asked this question before on both
occasions
it did have to be
described what the 250k was going to be
spent on
because it that wasn't clear really
uh though there was a program in there
so um
and the the um
cabinets sort of exploring
um
you know the detail
um certainly nobody did ask a question
on the on the um on the finances
but um
if they are already aware of what
that was then that's fine i'm not sure
that that helps the public who perhaps
are watching a public meeting but that's
a different issue altogether
so any more comments that we want to
make
i suppose i um
yeah a couple of comments one is that we
aren't here to scrutinize
um
the
sectioning off of the building that
that's not what we're here to scrutinize
we're here to scrutinize whether
the questions that were asked at cabinet
were probing enough in terms of the
finances
and the
the appropriateness of the building for
the staff to be working in it isn't our
question today is it
and just because if i can just repeat
and reiterate just because the questions
weren't asked doesn't mean that they
weren't understood maybe cabinet didn't
ask the questions because they they knew
the answers so they didn't need to ask
those questions
i do agree though that for members of
the public watching
um
some of those questions would have been
useful
just for the purposes of clarity to
members of the public really
um
[Music]
i think that's all i want to say on it
yes i mean i i actually support i mean i
said that because
yes in terms of the council 250 000
pounds
um
within a large budget of course it is
not as large but to the public 250 000
pounds is a lot of money
and uh it might have been helpful to
them if they'd have had some
understanding
of where that was going
can i just add that
um any members of the public who might
have been listening to the cabinet
meeting who felt that 250 pounds was a
large spend and they wanted it broken
down a little bit in terms of how many
screens how many desks etc i would
expect that concerned member of the
public
to have written in to have emailed into
a phoned in
is it appropriate to ask whether we have
had any questions for members of the
public
so this that the any members of the
public who may have been concerned
haven't been sufficiently concerned to
ask that question
um but i still think we need to be aware
of the sensitivities of our residents
and the questions that they may have
but it's it's perhaps worth noting that
no members of the public have come in
with questions about isn't 250 000
rather a lot to be spending or 500 000
really when you add mid suffix half but
that question hasn't been asked
and of course the other aspect of that
is council gold is that no other member
of the council
has actually asked
no other councillors asked the question
and
of course that is about whether
councillors are interested in cabinet
and
take an interest in decisions made by
cabinets so i think that is another
aspect of that that no no counsellor
will i imagine has not raised any
concerns either
yeah
well councillor melanie barrett did
the cabinet is there any counsellor as
councillor busby said at the cabinet
meeting any councillor is um has got the
opportunity to attend cabinet and listen
to cabinet decisions
so i mean perhaps we should encourage
that more amongst
members of the council yeah i agree
chair
right shall i just um
only should i just re-read the options
open to us
are we happy to conclude the debate
um
so the first so i'm going to read the
three
uh options for us to make a choice and
it will be an electronic vote
two options sorry
um
so the first option is refer the matter
back to the cabinet for reconsideration
together with the observations of the
overview and scrutiny committee cabinet
then will then take a final decision and
that decision cannot be called in
and the second option
is that the decision is upheld and
implemented immediately
emily do you want to give us any more
words of
advice
um thank you chair you've summarized the
two options available to the committee
and i think it's just now calling on a
committee member to propose one of those
options
and then take a second and then take a
vote thank you
okay can i just that the second option
is
that the decision of cabinet is upheld
isn't it yeah okay
well i would like to propose that second
option that the decision
um that the cabinet made originally is
upheld
so it's your second option chair i
believe
okay
shall we go to the
are we ready to go to the electronic
vote
and i'll have to get back in sorry
yes chair that vote is now in
progress on the app
chair that's three votes four
emily with this
decision um
we can't make any recommendations can we
no
no chair you can't make any specific
recommendations now because effectively
the item is closed however we will
report the outcome back to cabinet um
and of course the minutes of this
meeting will be available for the
cabinet's information so they will be
able to pick up some of the um
questions and points that you've made
during the debate today
yes i i would like to say that i um
we had to concentrate our minds on
the finances
and so we
explored all sorts of different
sort of aspects of the cabinet decision
so i would hope they would take note of
some of the
questions that were asked
are we to the end of the meeting
so i can i would like to conclude the
meeting thank you very much for your
attendance i would like to thank all the
officers who have um
well supported us that's um
um
and
emily and catherine and arthur's been
here and
the other emily and jan but i'd like to
thank our support in office henrietta
and bethany and alicia
these meetings can't
be undertaken without your help and
support so thank you very much and thank
you for coming
you